bonjour à tous alors il a dit que toutes
les conférences tedx démarre par une
histoire du coup je vais vous raconter
la mienne donc
l'histoire débute en 2006 à l'époque je
suis étudiant et j'ai effectué mon stage
de 2e année donc je suis en géo a donc
j'ai principalement profil marketing et
j'effectue du coup à ce stage dans une
association à but non lucratif aux états
unis dans la ville de seattle et ma
mission principale lors de cette mission
c'est de créer un moteur de recherche
pour une base de données donc je connais
pas grand chose en fait dans les
langages de programmation et on est que
je suis un profil marketing donc donc je
débute voilà je galère je galère un
petit peu et un beau jour vient m'aider
du coup un ingénieur en système
d'information et il va en fait débugger
mon code et toute la magie en fait qui
va apparaître ensuite va vraiment
m'étonner est en fait cette magie va
paraître au moment où cette personne va
mettre en ligne à mon programme via ce
qu'on appelle en serveur est en fait
l'ordinateur qu'ils utilisent
ce qui renvoie à l'écran c'est ça et je
sais pas si vous connaissez ce que c'est
mais en fait c'est ce qu'on appelle le
système d'exploitation gnu/linux
nouvelle gamme on appelle ça on appelle
ça linux et c'est vraiment la première
fois que je vois justement linux à
l'écran et jusqu'à présent j'en avais un
petit peu entendue comme à la météo
quand vous parle de mistral et
tramontane quoi c'est un amour comme ça
qui vous parle mais vous l'avez à vous
l'avez jamais vu et du coup j'ai eu une
révélation donc naturellement je vois
cet écran et je veux ma lui poser tout
un tas de questions je dis wow c'est
impressionnant salaire salaire super
technique qu'est ce que c'est exactement
est ce que tu peux m'en dire plus c'est
une des questions de luxe lui pose c'est
au ks salaire salaire difficile à
utiliser
est ce que c'est vraiment le cas et la
réponse qui va me donner qu'est vraiment
la clé de toute cette conférence donc
retenu bien du coup à ce qui ce qui va
me dire c'est ça c'est oui c'est dur
c'est difficile à utiliser donc ils
parlaient pas que de linux y parlait de
un petit peu de l'univers du logiciel
libre en tant que tel dont je vais vous
parler dans cette conférence
mais si tu y arrives en fait si tu
travailles dur si tu arrives à
comprendre ce qu'il ya derrière tu est
assuré d'avoir un job jusqu'à la fin de
tes jours et en fait je suis là
aujourd'hui tout simplement parce que
j'ai suivi son conseil et
j'ai atteint en fait ce qu'on appelle le
i qui gagne c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
je fais déjà je vis de l'univers du
logiciel libre sachant que je suis
quelqu'un du marketing
je fais quelque chose que j'adore je
suis super bien payés c'est à dire que
généralement je travaille à une journée
dans le mois et mon salaire il est déjà
est déjà fait et plutôt en bon salaire
aujourd'hui je fais vivre toute ma
famille grâce à ça c'est grâce au
logiciel libre que j'ai pu rencontrer ma
femme c'est grâce à saab a naturellement
par ricochet que du coup je suis
aujourd'hui l'heureux papa d'une petite
fille qu'à neuf mois et surtout j'ai
l'impression des ddd le monde entier est
également j'ai eu l'occasion de voyager
à travers le monde d'ailleurs je
continue encore à le faire et travailler
pour les plus grandes institutions et
pour les plus grandes entreprises de la
planète alors que que je n'ai que je
n'ai que 34 ans du coup cette conférence
je l'articuler de la manière suivante je
vais tout d'abord vous définir ce que
c'est qu'un logiciel libre ensuite je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi c'est
intéressant également comment rentrer
dans ce fameux l'univers du logiciel
libre alors le mot logiciels libres vous
l'avez probablement déjà entendu et vous
avez probablement déjà utilisé du
logiciel les branches vous est mis ici
quelques logiciels que vous connaissez
probablement un tel que libreoffice tels
que wordpress tels que gimp ou encore
firefox et je vais vous éviter en fait
tout le jargon un petit peu à technique
de la définition ce qu'un logiciel libre
je vais vous le gard is et tout ça elle
simplifier je veux dire plus en mode
marketing un logiciel libre en fait il
est défini par quatre libertés
fondamentales qui sont la première la
possibilité de pouvoir l'exécuter pour
toutes tâches que vous souhaitez donc
contrairement aux logiciels
propriétaires ou privateurs ce qui va se
passer c'est que vous n'êtes pas régis
par des conditions générales
d'utilisation vous avez signé vous vous
êtes engagé à utiliser le fameux
logiciel juste pour une fin bien définis
par le créateur de logiciels non avec un
logiciel vous êtes libre de faire ce que
vous souhaitez avec ça c'est la première
liberté
la deuxième liberté c'est la possibilité
d'analyser le code source à vous allez
dire qu'on a un profil en marketing ou
qu'on n'est pas dans le domaine de
l'informatique quel est l'intérêt de le
faire tout simplement de vérifier s'il
n'y a pas des données qui sont envoyées
à des tiers je savais qu'à chaque fois
on va vous parler de de vie privée le
fait que certains acteurs vont récupérer
des données que tel logiciel va envoyer
des données à droite à gauche baal
enterrait d'un logiciel libre c'est que
vous pouvez à tout moment investiguer ce
qu'il y a
enfin recherché et regarde en effet six
ans voit pas des données à des
entreprises auxquelles vous n'auriez pas
souhaité que ça envoie des données
troisième liberté c'est la possibilité
de voir faire du business avec s'avère
que c'est à dire que vous avez
possibilité de voir prendre le logiciel
de le modifier et derrière de pouvoir le
revendre par la suite typiquement c'est
le cas du world press je sais pas si
c'est un logiciel qui vous parle
mais il ya encore une dizaine d'années
on n'entendait pas beaucoup parlé de
voir presse aujourd'hui c'est quasiment
logiciel principal que utilisé pour
créer des sites web est aujourd'hui il
ya tout un paquet d'âge ans de micro
entrepreneurs qui ont réussi du coup à
lancer leur activité simplement parce
qu'ils ont récupéré ce logiciel créé des
sites internet pour des entreprises x ou
y est d'ailleurs revendre en fait le
site internet en tant que tel et le
client à lui derrière b récupère un site
intérêts qui lui appartient
intégralement et la 4e libertés
fondamentales c'est la possibilité
d'améliorer
du coup le logiciel c'est à dire la
possibilité de pouvoir modifier de
rajouter des fonctionnalités lui faire
faire ce que l'on souhaite
voilà donc si on devait comparer un
petit peu le logiciel libre à ce qu'on
appelle le logiciel propriétaire et et
privateurs bien imaginer que le logiciel
libre
c'est comme si vous décidez de
construire une maison vous êtes libre de
choisir le terrain que vous voulez vous
êtes libre de pouvoir choisir les
matériaux que vous allez utiliser pour
construire votre maison la taille de
votre maison et que cet art etc
lorsque vous utilisez du logiciel
propriétaire ou privateurs ce qui
représente à peu près on va dire pas
loin des 100 % du matériel et des
logiciels que vous achetez quand ben
voilà qu'on vous les achetez dans la
dans le commerce on est vraiment sur un
cas ou à voilà vous êtes locataire
donc vous êtes locataire d'un immeuble
sis voulait percer un trou bavouzet
falloir faut demander aux propriétaires
sous les repeindre les murs vous avez
pas droit non plus etc etc
voilà en fait la grosse différence entre
ce qu'est un logiciel libre qu'est-ce
qui est un logiciel propriétaire ou au
privateurs alors maintenant que josé
définit ce que c'est justement le
logiciel libre je vais vous expliquer un
petit peu pourquoi il est intéressant de
s'intéresser à l'univers de logiciels et
donc il ya quatre principales raisons
que j'ai pu identifier la première c'est
celle qui doit le plus vous préoccuper
c'est ce qu'ils appellent le problème
place code je sais pas combien d'entre
vous dans cette salle ont déjà entendu
parler du problème classe code
ok ça craint mais le programme classes
code
qu'est ce que c'est c'est simplement dès
l'âge de 8 ans
en fait demain les élèves ont la
possibilité du coup de suivre ce
programme donc vous pouvez taper classe
code dans un célèbre moteur de recherche
et vous trouverez le site est en fait
c'est tout un ensemble de ressources qui
sont là justement pour les éduquer à
l'univers du logiciel libre est
également à la pensée en informatique
donc c'est à dire que dès l'âge de 8 ans
ils ont la possibilité de savoir comment
créer un site web
qu'est ce que c'est qu'internet comment
créer un robot comment on crée son
propre programme
exeter et c est ce qui m'a fait flipper
dans ce programme classes code et qui
m'a fait vraiment revoir toute ma
méthodologie de travail toute ma
méthodologie d'enseignement à
l'université c'est le jour où j'ai
regardé ce qu'il y avait dans ce
programme classes code et le jour où
j'allais comparé à ce que moi
j'enseignais à mes étudiants à la
faculté au niveau master 1 master 2 en
marketing digital et j'ai vu que le
contenu c'était le même
d'accord c'était le même donc à gamin de
8 ans aujourd'hui il va ressortir avec
les mêmes connaissances les mêmes
compétences que les étudiants que je
formais à l'époque donc il ya deux trois
ans puisque maintenant j'ai revu toutes
mes reins méthodologie de travail
donc vous pouvez imaginez le truc c'est
à dire que dans dix ans quand ces gamins
là il faut sortir de l'école avec toute
cette expérience là qui vont être majeur
et qui vont pouvoir travailler
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'il va nous
arriver qu est ce que vous pensez qu'il
va vous arriver
habituellement ils vont vous dévorez
vous êtes les dinosaures de demain donc
ça c'est vraiment super important pour
vous c'est c'est de réaliser cette
partie là d'aller regarder ce qui se
passe dans le problème qu'a scott si
vous n'avez pas encore ce bagage en
culture numérique
la deuxième raison principale pour
laquelle vous devez absolument vous
intéresser à l'univers du jeu logiciel
libre c'est ce qu'a mis en évidence
justement edouard snowden donc il a mis
en évidence beaucoup de choses mais dans
ce qui a mis en évidence un moment donné
à ce qu'on appelle le programme prisme
d'accord le programme prisme il dit
simplement que la msa a accès à tout un
ensemble de services dégâts femmes y
compris comme on le voit ici du gmail du
skype et ses escales ses amarres on sait
que quand édouard snowden il a mis ça en
évidence donc maintenant des quasiment
sur une période de deux trois quatre
cinq ans le réflexe que le grand public
a eu sa répétées de dégager et tout ce
qui est skype tout ce qui est gmail etc
l'ordinateur n'en principalement ce
qu'ils ont trouvé comme moyen de défense
c'est ça c'est de prendre un post it et
se dit en fait j'ai de mettre sur ma
webcam comme ça on va pas savoir ce qui
se passe dans ma maison
mais il faut imaginer que ça en effet ça
permet de savoir que en effet on vous
voit pas quand vous êtes en train de le
faire
ou deux trucs comme ça mais
naturellement derrière ça empêche pas de
récupérer tout ce que vous dites
d'accord quand vous utilisez ces fameux
logiciel la troisième raison c'est pas
grethen berck c'est principalement
l'histoire du développement durable
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui la plupart
du matériel que vous avez qui est vendu
dans le commerce est vendu avec du
logiciel propriétaire
je vais prendre un exemple j'ai acheté
récemment du coup ce ce boîtier là donc
c'est une prise connecté en bluetooth
qui vous permet de pouvoir contrôler
derrière l'appareil que vous allez
branché et de contrôle et du coup
l'électricité qui passait de dire quand
est ce que tu veux arrêter quand est ce
que tu veux tu éteindre et et du coup
j'ai contacté un moment donné le
constructeur de cette fameuse prise et
je lui ai dit ok j'aimerais bien du coup
ap le gué ma propre ma propre
application at on à ton matériel pour
pouvoir contrôler du coup comme je veux
au final la prise et non pas via
l'application que tu as mis sur les
stores et le fabricant il m'a répondu ah
bah non c'est pas possible
moi je te donne pas je te donne pas la
possibilité de le faire je n'aime pas
les accès parce qu'on est justement ceux
du logiciel propriétaire et c'est assez
flippant parce que ça veut dire quoi se
dire que le jour où la boîte elle met la
clé sous la porte
ça ça file à la dèche est direct en fait
on peut pas leur cycle et on ferait
circuler cercle peut-être le plastique
en tant que telle la prison ça nous fait
une mini rallonge on va dire de 2 5 cm
mais en fait concernant la partie
logicielle en tant que tel ballet on
peut rien en faire
donc derrière c'est la dèche est il ya
tout un paquet comme ça de matériel qui
est bon à jeter à la poubelle tout
simplement parce que les fabricants ils
ont mis la clé sous la porte et la
partie logicielle n'est plus du tout
accessible et la quatrième raison pour
laquelle on devrait tous du coup
commencé à faire le nettoyage dans
toutes ces solutions
c'est un petit peu tout là toutes les
parties révolte qu'on voit actuellement
que ce soit ici les gilets jaunes où que
ce soit n'importe quelle manifestation
généralement aux problèmes de fond c'est
quoi c'est qu'il ya plus d'argent dans
les caisses de l'état
et pourquoi il ya plus d'argent dans les
caisses de thé de tabac tout simplement
parce que notre économie en tout cas une
grande partie notre économie elle tourne
sur la technologie dégâts femmes donc
aujourd'hui qu'on ne serait ce que vous
regardez autour de vous vous auront
trait dans un bus ou dans un lieu public
mairie que les gens sont physiquement
avec vous mais une grande partie 2 sont
aussi présents dans l'univers du digital
via leur smartphone via leur ordinateur
portable et ce en train d'utiliser des
technologies dégâts femmes donc les gars
femmes sont en train de se mettre
de l'argent des poches et du cou puis on
va continuer à utiliser ces fameux
technologie plus du coup notre économie
va s'appauvrir aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
d'autre manière de faire que justement
de se mettre autour de son ordinateur de
développer ensemble avec tous les autres
pays
justement ces fameuses briques en
logiciels libres et de se mettre
progressivement à construire notre
propre infrastructure numérique
donc voilà tout ça c'était toi c'est un
petit peu flippant voyons maintenant un
petit peu comment on rentre dans cet
univers du logiciel libre
alors j'ai identifié quatre principales
manières de pouvoir rentrer dans cet
univers de logiciels libres et elles
sont toutes complémentaires
la première c'est vraiment de réaliser
et ça c'est dur à avaler les réaliser au
bout de vraiment au bout de dix ans
c'est de réaliser qu'on est mauvais
c'est à dire de réaliser que la raison
pour laquelle on n'utilise pas ces
logiciels c'est principalement parce que
la première fois qu'on les ouvre ou
qu'on les a lancés il ya un message
d'erreur qui s'est présentée à nous en
fait ce n'est pas vraiment un message
d'erreur ce cas c'est qu'un logiciel
libre il peut être configuré de mille et
une manières possibles et inimaginables
et ce qu'il ya c'est que si on n'a pas
compris justement qu'on peut le
configurer de manière différente et
qu'on doit le configurer en fonction de
nos besoins
il éclaire net qu'on va jamais réussir à
le trouver suffisamment instinctif
comparer un logiciel justement à
propriétaire est déjà bien défini parce
que son fabricant a souhaité faire donc
ça c'est vraiment la première chose à
faire deuxième c'est d'accepter
d'investir et d'investir jld c'est pas
forcément de l'argent c'est d'investir
du temps c'est de se dire que de la même
manière que lorsqu'on construit pour la
première fois sa maison la première fois
qu'on se met à je dirais innover dans
son appartement dans sa maison bah il
éclaire n'être que le premier trou que
vous avez percée dans le mur ce n'était
pas forcément un succès d' accord à des
choses que vous avez permis tribun là
c'est la même chose il va falloir
accepter justement de passer du temps
régulièrement essayer de comprendre
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un ordinateur
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un site web
qu'est ce que c'est qu'internet tout
simplement parce que vous allez
continuer à utiliser de plus en plus ces
machines et si vous voulez c'est au
final les gars femme vous fait et
continue à vous imposer un petit peu la
règle vous n'arriverez pas à comprendre
tout l'univers qui tourne autour
la troisième chose à faire c'est de
construire c'est à dire que vous pouvez
pas vous en sortir
si vous manipulez pas si vous créez pas
c'est à dire que quel que soit votre
profil
il va falloir à un moment donné que vous
acceptiez de vous lancer dans la
création de votre propre site web dans
la création de vos propres classeur
numérique vous pouvez pas imaginer
le nombre de start-up pour qui j'étais
que pour qui j'ai travaillé qui sont
pourtant des des fleurons de l'industrie
française voire même européenne est le
premier réflexe kizomba en fait c'est
chouette on voudrait un google drive et
on va tous les documents de
l'entreprise dessus c'est cool c'est
génial comme ça t'en vois tout est
secret de fabrication directement à
google et comment tu veux derrière au
final que ne serait-ce que la france ou
l'europe en fait arrive à sortir des
champions c'est pas possible puisque de
base c'est ce que tu es en train de
faire je sais pas tant enseignants et
enseignants tu prends un google drive et
tu mets les notes de tout et étudiants
du coup à l'intérieur d'un d'un classeur
dans ce match il se passe quoi il se
passe que le jour où google il veut
recruter
est-ce qu'il a accès en effet à
l'ensemble des notes des étudiants est
ce qu'il sait qu'ils sont les meilleurs
profils ben ouais esquissait qui sont
les mauvais bah oui le sait également en
fait c'est juste de la logique ça à
chaque fois de vous dire j'utilise tel
logiciel à qu'ils appartiennent et au
final est ce que ces logiciels ils ont
intérêt à un moment donné de venir
piocher dedans et d'analyser ce qui se
passe donc voilà ça c'est justement la
partie la partie construction c'est
vraiment il faut que vous construisez
vos propres trucs et en effet c'est un
combat un petit peu de tout les jours
quoi monter son propre serveur s'est
jamais fun moi ça me faisait flipper que
c'est un mais au final avec le temps on
y arrive et les quatrièmes choses et qui
est selon moi également un des facteurs
de succès du logiciel libre c'est de
partager
en fait c'est de contribuer c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui pourquoi ces logiciels
paraissent un petit peu instinctif tout
simplement parce que toute la
documentation qui est accessible en
ligne et mises en ligne justement par
les personnes qui ont créé ces fameux
logiciel et eux ils sont de l'univers du
technique donc naturellement si pour
ceux et celles qui sont pas l'univers
technique vous vous expliquer pas vous
quels sont les freins que vous avez
rencontré si vous expliquez pas vous à
d'autres personnes si vous prenez pas
soin d ancienne génération
comment voulait justement que ces
anciennes générations arrivent aussi à à
passer le cap et arriver à comprendre
comment les utiliser et les manipuler et
en fait c'est l'effort que j'ai fait du
coup cet été j'ai accepté par exemple de
pas me payer pendant deux mois et
pendant deux mois j'ai créé du coup
cette fameuse plateforme pour mes
semblables quand je dis mes semblables
c'est les profils ans en marketing ce
qu'on appelle la floss marketing school
et l'objectif justement cette forme et
gratuitement librement tous les profils
en marketing digital voire même tout
individu à travers le monde sur
justement l'utilisation de ces fameuses
technologie mais à des fins de marketing
digital
comment au lieu d'utiliser le moteur de
recherche google
créer aussi son propre moteur de
recherche et on peut arriver à
comprendre le fonctionnement d'un moteur
de recherche même chose en ce qui
concerne tout ce qui va avec l'analyse
d'audience où un e-mailing et s'est
séparé c'est ce fameux projet que
j'écris et pour conclure je vais vous
montrer simplement quelque chose de tout
simple c'est une maison cette maison a
été construite en fait part par mon
grand-père un qui nous a quittés du coup
y'a il ya deux ans et en fait lors de la
cérémonie d'adieu
la prêtresse a dit la chose suivante
elle a dit qu'il avait souhaitée du coup
passé ces derniers jours ces dernières
heures dans la maison qu'il avait
construite de ses propres mains et cette
phrase là elle m'a marqué parce que mon
grand père il était pas maçon en fait il
était dessinateur industriel et je pense
que ça doit être un peu le même cas pour
pour pour vous pour ceux qui ont des
grands-parents
c'est de se dire que en fait à l'après
guerre il y avait tout à reconstruire
quoi et même si ce n'était pas le
travail de nos grands-parents bas ils y
sont allés du coup au charbon ils ont
appris justement à prendre soin d'un
jardin à créer un mur à choisir les bons
qu'opposants et à faire avec ce qu'ils
avaient pour au final on sur la maison
est aujourd'hui la situation qu'on a
c'est la suivante c'est nous on a un
univers qui était plutôt favorable et
pour construire notre univers basse et
c'est un simple ordinateur et
aujourd'hui on a peur de notre
ordinateur parce qu'au premier message
des ordres ou là c'est trop technique
j'ai besoin du coup d'appeler un
développeur et voilà pour terminer je
voulais simplement vous dire qu'en fait
d'un autre futur votre futur il effaça
vous en fait tous les jours c'est votre
écran d'ordinateur
il reste plus qu'à vous de de le changer
ce futur merci à vous
[Applaudissements]